citizens of the reject nation is time to
demolish a man I've never seen
Demolition Man John no has never seen
demolition ever you know what I know
about this movie what do you know
Travolta nope still alone
Wesley Snipes yes always Taco Bell oh
that's all I know I'm at the Pizza Hut
I'm at the Taco Bell I'm watching
Demolition Man with koi and John
Travolta so we're gonna dive into this
classic grease sequel Demolition Man I'm
excited now please leave a like leave a
comment let us know what you thought of
this experience of us this is probably
the most classic movie I have zero
exposure I've even seen a trailer so I'm
very excited to find out what's going on
here like you did that thumbs up so you
can let us know that you liked what was
going on here and I would like to thank
G fuel for helping us fuel what's going
on here drink of the future right there
hear that hear that that's energy that's
success that's Victory and it's
quenching hit the link in the
description and use promo code reject
Nation for 20 off select tubs you would
like to watch our entire experience head
on over to the patreon become a super
sexy reject to watch us from beginning
to end start to finish fueled all the
way through with our resting watching
faces
so get on over there and be a patreon
without further Ado let's watch
Demolition Man in three two one
no oh no
I didn't live here yet but I assume this
is the future I've seen the Los Angeles
destroyed so many times in recent
memories 96 is a rough year for a lake
it's okay New York's been taking a
beating in a lot of these movies that's
true let's mix it up go west coast
remember when they stole that commercial
abandon this town
well we're going or why the hell we're
bother it anyhow
it's very clean Maniac hijacked a Miss
will budget 30 passengers on it that's a
pretty good reason and I got a real bad
hunch where those passengers are with a
media case you want to share it with us
Phoenix
Simon Phoenix there's a name Simon
Phoenix damn diving into the ashes
Phoenix
this is where Cap got it from it was in
a comic but maybe it's after Stallone
all greatest action moments are inspired
by Stallone it's true
[Music]
let's go boy yeah
Expendable zero he just said it takes a
maniac to catch one yes what a great
opening five minutes live I love this
yeah
first couple minutes you know exactly
what kind of movie you're in yeah
the running shoot
like this Dutch angle coverage yeah it
is great
[Music]
a man can Hench and shoot
he's got to do another Dutch he can do
it all who shot this movie I love it
these stunts hit hard so does he
[Music]
extreme close-ups are killing it got my
anime villain Knife Man the 90s were
just going don't move Phoenix
you're under arrest for tax evasion
arrested a new trespass uh oh where
are the passengers well they're all
you
this is between you and me
and this gun what what you guys do
something soldier boy oh he's standing
in it
is it cold in here or is it just me yeah
come on dude you had to know
[Music]
type of cop League he's in yeah
Snipes outfit also killing it yeah dude
those Beetlejuice pants the near future
of fashion I swear I lose my head it
wasn't attached
yeah I was gonna come back later oh yeah
you think he's beheaded I think he gets
beheaded
canisters but why
[Music]
let's get every angle every shot
uh when they used to actually blow up
warehouses yeah right
you know
I've been up to that title right at the
top this neat building needed to be
demolished he's doing the city of
service oh Wesley Snipes is just
Demolition Man stolen's trying to stop
yes he doesn't like the way he does it
you're not supposed to come down here
you are not supposed to tempt the arrest
of Phoenix and you are not supposed to
blow anything up
that's what cops are supposed to do all
that stuff trying to nail this cycle for
two years try remembering a little thing
called Official Police procedure weapon
which you haven't seen yet soon it'll be
more exciting this is a crossover
bodies everywhere it must be 20 or 30.
see that Captain I told him
oh my God it was a great cold open sure
these like superhero at odds and God
what a hook too you think he's like
swooping in badass saving the day 20 30
people die yeah Joel Silver at the
height of his powers this is like what
six years out from Matrix
foreign
Smithers acting as assistant Warden
hereby carry out this sentence
you've been sentenced to 70 years
Sub-Zero rehabilitation in the
California cryo Penitentiary for the
involuntary manslaughter 30 innocence
that is a jacked man you'll be eligible
for parole no earlier than the year
2046. wow Blade Runner 2046. Jesse
Ventura too
he's a different kind of cut God pan
down cowards
show what's the Stallone oh Jackie is
downstairs I mean they called him the
Italian style I was just gonna be sent
into the future
naked you know
what a weird pose to free somebody
squatting also what is if they're frozen
how do they rehabilitate yeah
just like taking a nap
oh yeah so close boys so close well
shaded you looked
[Music]
did that go extra milky okay make sure
it's a little cloudy right over there
Hollywood see my Italian style I named
them Adrian I don't get any of them
titles
that's a frozen man
[Music]
his name is Spartan he had John Spartan
and Simon Phoenix it's like freaking
face off in here
this does feel a little bit of a
face-off-esque certainly it's a good
good time
not yet ready for parole but still the
future
so much he's aware yeah he's thinking in
there he's alive it's not great it's
only nine years away a weird 2032 is
only nine years away oh don't remind me
of things like that right now Koi No I'm
here to be whisked away into a fanciful
future all right on a fanciful horrible
present
fellow greetings young Sandra Bullock
I'm hereby querying you on the prison
population update close in the car does
the TDM continue the prison has her ice
cubes they never move great Exposition
conversation guys this feels very
authentic I'll fiber off you back after
the morning parole hearing a fiber opt
you back we have fiber he's basically on
an iPad she's driving a Tesla right now
yeah this is like not as far
goes
[Music]
be well oh he's a Smithers too oh he's
the same Smither she's just older that
should have been obvious I was like his
son
[Music]
what cool on Earth
life is hell
I'm just gonna go out and say a future
taggers are not as cool as attackers
Food Glorious Food could be another one
in about 12 hours talk about Cuisine
valet people are hungry we got nothing
left to lose
get that Taco Bell Dennis Leary looking
like Bo Burnham in the side
there's this subplot of Rob Schneider
action movies they're all connected
they're all set in this universe these
outfits I monitored your disheartening
and distressing comments to the warden
this morning do you really long for
chaos and disharmony
sanctimonious
violation of the verbal moralities
put one in the swear jar oh it's amazing
I love this future
whoa that was tense don't you get bored
code tracing perps who break curfew and
tell dirty jokes oh I find my job deeply
fulfilling I find their jokes very funny
you're still addicted to the 20th
century The Joker hi from its harshness
buzzed by its brutality
blood sugar Sex Magic Red Hot Chili
Peppers 29 years ago the parole system
as you know it
what 5
37-20s
stop it
stop speaking Spanish
[Music]
actually just steps off
I took a fight man
whoa how do you know the password to the
custom I wish I knew it Simon says
let's get this over quickly oh
Smithers
[Music]
Jesus Christ you too
I love this movie
amazing it's got like Fifth Element
Vibes there's like a lot this is
this is Street Fighter to face-offs
Mortal Kombat yes 100 what's a 187
identify code 187 MDK murder death
killer whoa an MDK a murder death kill I
love that band
Smithers injuries severe eye drama
condition critical
finds failing failing oh and my dude in
the chair
[Music]
oh yeah
it's great Peterson Scott 7 30.
Simon Phoenix's code now access code for
Phoenix Simon he was chill back during
the 20th before they started lojacking
everybody
declared his own kingdom
he's done one of everything busy guy in
the 80s and 90s main cryo prison parking
Zone
image oh no
I ceased he's a doctor's conveying still
in the parking Zone the answer is no and
he murdered death killed all the other
cars tires just in time mixing location
Beverly Hills Robertson
Beverly Drive hey accurate proceed with
extreme assertiveness
as high-fiving's too violent I just
gotta get to like Placid and and you
know innocuous everything is so sterile
Super Mario that outfit is amazing
anything special about me you are an
incredibly sensitive man who inspires
joy joy feelings in
I need this machine Oh I wanna Street
therapist Angeles Information Network
automated banking whoa Jesus friendly
Edgar listed offenses civil unrest
activities
I don't think in regular life better
there it looked like it
[Music]
get like hacked hacked prio if your
friendly Must Die oh no he's got a
murder death kill him referred to as a
pistol look I don't need a history
lesson come on Hal where the goddamn Go
sing me a song why don't you violation
of the verbal morale
oh my God
remain we're gonna come tackle you for
dropping a couple of bombs
they're coming for different reasons but
also request advice
Maniac light down excuse me maniac
oh I'm so scared
approach and repeat ultimatum in an even
firmer tone of voice add the words or
else
lie down on the ground
or else
override it you got this
whoa that is the anti-graffiti system
martial arts cut to a wide show us some
of those moves you cast them for a
reason for police officers we're gonna
try to handle this kind of violence
hahaha
you better start learning
Simon Says everybody
[Music]
[Applause]
that guy lost even stand up nope he's
out he's out he's on the rest of the
movie man that man's playing Galaga that
we wouldn't notice but we did the real
problem lies in the man whose initials
marked the detonating graffiti The Man
Behind the EF Mr Edgar friendly
e f men and women who have left the
comfort of our society only dispute
hostility at the very bosom that they
have relinquished
you far-fetched this radical terrorist
Behavior led by Mr friendly must not be
allowed
from Beetlejuice and stuff oh yeah yeah
a cryocon has affected self-release from
the penitentiary murder death kills all
categories of Chaos
that's your calm you got it Mel Brooks I
want you to do everything in your power
to snare this agent of distraction it's
very male books you have my utmost
confidence
how is the fiendish Simon Phoenix
apprehended back in the 20th Trail State
Manhunt wow
fight on Unsolved Mysteries hey
he's back
in the end it took just one man John
Spartan
called him the Demolition Man
there you go yeah they did there you
have a title good how can
[Music]
[Applause]
you
oh that's so good it's the principal you
could reinstate him Simon Phoenix is an
old-fashioned criminal we need an
old-fashioned cop
true that boy this this one's so good
let's do it switch their faces yeah it's
due gotta find out what happens to catch
an old-fashioned criminal in an
old-fashioned cop the Demolition Man
[Music]
uncomfortable position to be asleep in
yeah it's gonna be stiff let's see him
oh he's gonna Terminator out of there
[Music]
yeah owner Stallone saw Arnold and was
like I will be more shredded and more
naked yeah
I am Lieutenant lanina Huxley the years
2032. it's not like a process
and we froze your whole family her light
was extinguished in the big one of 2010.
the big one the big one
she died in an earthquake
the earthquake don't you remember the
2010 earthquake
I'm chief of police George Earl we
didn't thaw you out for a family reunion
because they're dead because they are
dead
this is about you and the cryocons Simon
Phoenix how are you telling him
[Applause]
yes of course right away
what's a sugar at any cigarette I mean
that's pretty accurate too smoking is
not good for you and has been deemed
that anything not good for you is bad
hence illegal alcohol caffeine contact
sports meat are you me well
snowflake future is this bad language
chocolate gasoline uneducational toys
and anything spicy chocolate has
memories everything's offense oh good
for dopamine he went to the bathroom I I
guess he got all thought out oh
oh dread nice formally convey my
presence
they used handfuls of wadded paper back
in the 20s
what an idiot you got this little Shelf
with three seashells on it he doesn't
know how to use the three seashells
she's just walking around
poopy back there what's happening with
the shells someone explained the shells
Zach's lamb I got older but not too old
for this
he finally grounded me
[Music]
toilet paper out of swearing
now that is a magic trick
just going for a gun the only place a
person can even view a gun in this city
is
uh at a museum whoa it belongs in a
museum well that's where we might find
him you said it boy they're doing such a
cool job of making the past the the the
present the past and using like this
era's present as artifacts yeah like the
posters the pop culture this is great
well
Huxley Aldous Huxley Brave New World
nicely done sci-fi
clever clever he's a Spartan warrior a
man of bare bones Integrity Spartan
Phoenix From the Ashes first one woken
up wall to wall mini Tunes you call them
commercials
play the McDonald's song this is my
nightmare play State Farm
[Music]
oh you'll be there soon enough
the Armory exhibit you will find display
wow
[Music]
this is what I'm talking about you got
to wait that 15 day waiting period oh
can I just like take one nap
oh
Drew Santino
how much do you weigh
S I happen to wait for this oh my
goodness no that is
okay didn't expect here we are hey Luke
Skywalker use the force hey what the
hell is this oh it's a blow rod that's
the lightsaber we got does it work
[Music]
wow I guess so wow that's that's just a
cattle prod
they're all in that 90s
[Music]
oh boy the museum is no longer sealed is
it I'm a blast from the past
yes you are who is that I was hungry
and I was using a future Canon
[Music]
Simon Says bleed
the music in the Hall of violence oh
yeah
this is the Hall of sick beats
yeah buddy
you gotta get charged for that
oh snap
is the city like buried yeah right on
top of it it looks like it passes over
John time
good job
[Music]
yeah get that kick
the boxer versus the kickboxer it's
great
Soulja Boy tell him you're on TV
[Music]
TV's on you
Simon Says
him back the way he got him electricity
fire mirroring great
[Music]
there you go
I think Brave New World does have a more
like docile future so the stress breeder
is inside being demobilized as we speak
stress bringer don't worry I'll get you
with the next shot I don't think so
no kiss kiss no bang bang
how do you like that Shane black Mr
Edgar friendly
don't you have someone to kill I'm gonna
take it you programmed him yes he is
just going out with a hunch here
then go and do your job
Saved by the Bell
how much did Taco Bell Peck
I'm very curious got a tagline there's
only been one photo like a little tag so
far I gotta say I was expecting more
tacos Taco Bell Demolition Man was
important it's all I know you scared him
away I I don't know how to thank you you
saved my life
no problem those hats who is this man
detective John Spartan temporarily
reinstated you've told us to do
everything in our power to capture the
madman oh yes yes I did
oh that's right oh there's another
one okay I would like you to accompany
me to Taco Bell
they're okay
all right let's go uh look forward to it
very excited about it give me the
crunches in here yeah and then brought
the Mexican pizza back in 2021 and
that's when you're in the right side of
that leap those five years were dark for
Humanity and when Phoenix performs
another murder death kill we'll know
exactly where to pounce great plan thank
you
Brad just looks like he's here from a
high school or something I love it
that was San Diego I think or San Diego
one of those places we're going to
Comic-Con at Taco Bell I'm at the
combination Comic-Con at Taco Bell
Schwarzenegger Library
residential Library president
Schwarzenegger after Governor he was
President yes even though he was not
born in this country his popularity the
time caused the 61st Amendment which
states
[Music]
amazing is this when the Rivalry was
ending it must have been I guess oh
that's so good or was this in relation
to When The Simpsons predicted president
Schwarzenegger I mean probably before
that I didn't expect you to kill
somebody
love that spell you ask me biscuits and
gravy I could go for biscuits and gravy
yeah sounds good so let's talk about
Echo friendly prepare for Simon Phoenix
I like Mexican food your town is quasi
and facetious but you do not realize
that Taco Bell was the only restaurant
to survive the franchise War the
franchise Wars now all restaurants are
Taco Bell
the franchise where's all restaurants or
Taco Bell I love their redesigned logo
oh this is so good
wait
it's a fancy
fans it's actually Mexican food now oh
my God
all restaurants at Taco Bell aren't they
making like upscale Taco Bells now it's
leading to this we're getting there oh
my God you aren't here when the real
disturbances began
civilization tried to destroy itself of
course the city degenerated into a total
fear Zone the citizenry cocooning in
their homes afraid to go out people just
wanted the madness over let's have Taco
Bell
[Music]
work in any 80s movies but my cryo
sentence was no sweet lullaby I had
feelings and I had thoughts how about a
36 year nightmare about people caught in
a burning building oh
and my wife beating her fist against a
block of ice that used to be her husband
then you were nice enough to wake me up
and let me know everything that meant
something in my life is gone wow
side effects of the cryo process are
unavoidable you were found guilty of
criminal charges
don't attack the Taco Bell
[Music]
yeah tennis Leary let's go Bo the scraps
oh my God
[Music]
yes oh my God unless they're like Tire
shoulder pads yeah the bad back
he knows how to do violence you gotta
regret just the rest of your life
I like that cut in for the second life
that they added later both seconds of it
[Applause]
foreign
that's all I see when I see him in this
movie
well done
[Music]
please don't
oh I've seen that guy in a gif I'm very
excited for the like you're just kind of
survive speech are this like vitamins
who are those guys they're known as
scraps outcasts and deserters who choose
to live beneath us in sewers and
abandoned tunnels the morlocks
the wild west wasn't even the wild west
hurting people's not a good thing oh
sometimes it is but not when it's a
bunch of people looking for something to
eat
oh
um you're going against their way being
like that did you something tells me
this tranquil future is not all that it
seems ah perhaps the scraps will get a
humanizing moment soon I keep looking
around and I think about my daughter
growing up in a place like this and I'm
afraid she's gonna think I'm some kind
of primitive I mean as much as I want to
see her I've been on the convention
center is she his daughter that'd be
weird only if they kiss that would be
weird Little Star Wars I could do a
search for you
oh sorry
I just feel very protective of you all
of a sudden um I got what you wanted oh
great
oh my remember how cool tiny CDs used to
be remember the phase of mini discs yeah
before the iPod there were the mini
discs how did you get in wish I knew I
got it pass the codes complete access to
the industrial data grid interface now I
don't even know what that means
that was why you were rehabilitated was
that what we're going to call it I'll
need about five or six more special men
his tire outfit is so good I have a list
wouldn't want you to defrost any of
those Mad Dog killer types you know what
I mean and none of them
from New York I want Jason Statham Terry
Crews Randy Couture Expendables foreign
[Music]
once I'll take care of them again deceit
lights
oh my what do you think the Jukebox and
everything the perfect 20th century
apartment
isn't it I'm a Pepsi girl
before like Taco Bells
it's a Pepsi technically survived the
fast food that's true it's true not so
much a causal effect but a general state
of neurological arousal I after having
observed your you this evening oh my I
was wondering if you would like to have
sex
oh my it's like
oddly kind of sweets you
know
[Music]
oh yeah oh yeah
how do we do it what is sex what is sex
in this era as presented so formally
what
this is strange days right now we're
gonna do some playback right here watch
again in a few seconds
what like physical contact people don't
like to touch in this world that's what
I'm thinking yeah I'm so worried
[Music]
oh
my oh wow
[Music]
always wanted to make love inside the
light at a rave
disco
what is happening oh my
[Music]
God
I wanna I want all the uninterrupted
b-roll of this scene yes
all right I'll see what do you say we're
just doing the old-fashioned way oh
disgusting disgusting
the exchange of bodily fluids do you
know what that leads to yeah I do okay
smoking a desire to rate the fridge
not even mouth transfers condoned she's
not allowed damn that was a good kisser
oh a Bad Bet procreation yeah we go to a
lab fluids are purified screened and
transferred by authorized medical
personnel only is the only legal way oh
boy
no no what are you doing
let's try breaking the law oh
you are a Savage creature John Spartan
and I wish you to leave my domicile now
top 10 weirdest mainstream sexy yep
that's why we need sex scenes in movies
like this I agree that I want the
cutscenes of just alone
so good
I want all my clothes to just be shaped
to show off all the best features like
Stallone gets to design like what if
I've got like a mandarin color oh it
doesn't matter
that'll be the post credit I want to
explain a video yeah
it's got like a tonal you just look like
you're like ready to train in some
martial arts temples
I don't think so
wow it's got all the angles too camera
technology has not improved
nope here I made this video
wow
that incredible work there's a cable
knit and everything damn it's so fast
when I fill it out the first thing I
wanted to do is knit I mean how come I
know what a zipper foot and a shuttle
and a hook and bobbin and a petty point
is I can weave a throw rock right now
with my eyes closed do it
for each inmate the computer draws up a
skill or trade which Best Suits their
genetic disposition and it would implant
the knowledge and the desire to carry
out whatever training was assigned
engineered to sew Venus comes out and he
can access computers operate all
vehicles know the location of every damn
thing in town and three times stronger
than when he went in
all right Fair
Sailors used to sew and knit and stuff
very easy that's fine but also yeah
comparatively useful Who develops these
programs well cocktail Industries
dehabilitation mellow apologies for my
lack of physical disposition detective
but I do have an entire city Gap to Run
Devil Run This
they're outside the museum why didn't he
blow your brains out it doesn't matter
yeah it matters I saw the security disk
full 10 seconds to figure out where to
put the hole in your
no this display of barbaric Behavior was
unacceptable even at your time shoot the
computer
[Applause]
Phoenix has a gun to your head 10
seconds is nine and a half seconds
longer than you live oh it's a good line
to solve all the difficulties in life
kill the Game of Thrones guy chaos in
the museum was the result of Mr
Phoenix's presence or your own
wonder about this wow what the
what what where was he he shot the
computer so he was in that room I guess
no no but I'm saying like he was
physically there how is he here he must
have been recording in the Next Room
your family's dead your past is dead
enjoy your moment of prehistoric bravado
because after you leave here it will be
over return this man to cryostasis
immediately
[Music]
It's the Best Best Line in all film
history
how did he transport into that room now
they're in Burbank
I hope you know what you're doing he
just left 20 leaves what's happening why
are you proceeding into the depths of
wasteland Phoenix was in the one place
that a you can't monitor B you're afraid
to go and Steve don't give a about
him
[Music]
uh but late before the end of days yes
yes now this is just where Bud Light
ends up after being Progressive it's
down here you know what happens the
dregs the dregs of society all I want is
a burger and a beer if you got one
how am I gonna pay bucks leaders
in any generation Rolex means money
oh no thank you that would taste so good
if you're only eating veggies and the
sadness just don't ask where the meat
comes from okay yes
[Music]
this is a red bird
a bed
matter of fact I've had in years
I mean it does look kind of satisfying I
gotta not think about it cows are smart
friendly animals I eat them delicious
car I see do you know what this is a
1970 Oldsmobile 442
unit with a 455 cubic inch engine radial
tires and bucket seats willikers
so did I
do it low right your friends too come on
let's go Bo
we're looking for a murder death killer
can you help or just bully us with your
primitive weapons
you tell Kato it's gonna take an army
to get rid of me because I
don't give a I got nothing to lose
but I don't know who the hell you are
let alone want to take you anywhere so
stay here be well
[Music]
you're the guy outside Taco Bell
what do you want
guys
Taco Bell is the third lead In fairness
I'm the kind of guy that just certainly
boosted spoon and wonder cheat should I
have the T-bone steak or the jumbo rack
of barbecue ribs with the side order
gravy fries I want high cholesterol
buckets of cheese okay I want to smoke
Cuban cigar the size of Cincinnati in a
non-smoking section yeah I've seen this
did you know what it is it's a 47 year
old virgin sitting around in his face
pajamas drinking a banana broccoli Shake
singing I'm an Oscar Meyer weed don't
talk about Steve Carell like that why
don't you take charge and leave these
people out of here I do what I have to
do
sometimes people come with me all I want
to do is bury cocktail up to his neck
and and let him think happy happy
thoughts forever
[Music]
black
correct cut back was it it actually
looks like him yeah it tracks for when
he was doing like video game commercials
the world has become
whipped Brady Bunch version of itself
Jesse Ventura yay we get the kill the
man who put most of us behind the priest
we get to kill John Spartan exactly
no two for the price of one that's
chicken boys
whoa oh that's clever we had reached the
point at which I am not sure where this
is gonna end up I'm still trying to
figure out how he teleported next to
that poke guy I know
it's like my second
extra blade I'm so happy for him this is
just mad cap Glee
okay
God damn like a New York approach
as big as one
oh that was cool good shot
yes
definitely not getting that High School
Credit Now nope it's all been taken
detention even
did his heterochromia eye change is it
now on the other side
thought it the left eye was blue right
eye was blue just then oh no maybe it
was a shot they had to reverse if they
had to physically because I don't think
you get a contact wrong that seems
pretty someone's there to take pictures
guys yeah move please
Christ's sake
oh that's a beautiful car it's a new
Oldsmobile dealership
geez
[Music]
that's the LA tunnel all right I like
how they feature it up just enough yeah
yeah it's really make it feel like we
went there all the way
[Music]
oh boy oh no
emergency
[Music]
God
[Applause]
oh doors off
dude
they were already dead
[Music]
it's a Twist that's fun
speak for yourself
you gotta still be able to use the wheel
with the thing in contracted
[Music]
all right
oh Mr suds
oh I guess it fills oh okay okay it
looked like soap science
is that Gonna Save you you know you
packing up of it in there there's no way
that's the end of Wesley Snipes
it's a good thing he works out gotta get
out of that phone
you're in shambles don't worry I can fix
it later when it's ready
it is useful true take the car and leave
the cannoli he did both friendship Red
Alert
Benjamin Bratz with them
bumping the Noggin and you think you're
Pancho Pia
oh
time to take a stand pal well good and
while you're doing it loan me a gun loan
me two guns
there'll be ten guns
let me two guns I hadn't counted on this
but I must say you work out beautifully
what's new people have always been
terrified of me you may ask but this
time they're really intimidating
did I have a twin
good shot you can't take away people's
right to be that's what you
remind me of an evil Mr Rogers
[Music]
come on man you didn't think that far
Jesse Ventura right there I can do
oh brother
[Music]
painful speak with the police are here
Proto blade move yeah
[Music]
oh come on
whoa
right in the line to get the whole H
gets brutal
good shot someone that hasn't used a gun
oh
um Jackie Chan movies yeah
it's good the classics
my peer your grandfather looks like the
cocktail player just went up in smoke
[Music]
I see what you did there I see what you
did his access to cryo prison he's about
to defrost the entire multi life for
wing
so they don't like you
how many are there
80. oh
I Now understand that under certain
circumstances that violence is necessary
good
whoa
it's for your own safety damn she's
gonna come save your ass at some point
yes okay
we missed some Snipes blood shots and
that was that was definitely an ad-lib I
hope my butt didn't look like that thank
you very much but your services will no
longer be required
oh yeah
oh boy
send a maniac to catch a maniac yeah
that's what I say to myself every time
before I come into the office every time
we're gonna do a reaction I'm like you
know what takes too many eggs to react
to Mania
[Music]
you have to jump
yeah reload
the clock it moves
[Music]
gonna lose your place in the new
Administration
[Music]
puns for days
oh boy oh dear dude
[Music]
oh
what a fun set piece yeah
how is Batman gonna thwart The Joker
this time he is 100 an Immaculate Joker
alt oh please Wesley Snipes Joker I want
it it's so fun
[Music]
come on smash it next time it hits
oh
dudes
[Music]
hey there's a dude in there
I mean there was
oh my God laser gat
oh no
you know I'm full pouts
[Music]
there's no reanimation sequence now
hey when things go wrong oh yes is it
cold in here or is it just me no it's an
Arnold line
and let's kick some ice there must be
some Spartans in the atmosphere
uh
sir Fair weird time to say it this late
in the game man I get it
[Music]
they're both so legitimately fast yeah
oh
[Music]
foreign
oh yeah you gotta get the rain gotta get
the rain this is the best
it's the best day of mine
[Music]
yeah
that's how they get each other every
time
[Music]
he Jason asked him
oh
the Headless thing the Headless thing
did come back it's Jason Takes Manhattan
with the head punch combined with the
Jason X nitrous mask done everything we
needed in the 90s oh man he lost his
head
practical explosion do it
I want to switch the shots personally I
would I would have had him run and then
I mean it's it's okay it's okay it's
okay I took his head off how will we
live I'll tell you what we're gonna do
we're gonna go and drink it all of us
get shit-faced and paint the town
literally they're graffiti slogans it'll
be a blast whoa whoa whoa I'm gonna tell
you what you're gonna do then it's like
you're from Boston you were lucky
and somewhere in the middle I don't know
you'll figure it out
yeah well done Benjamin brat you're a
man today he learned it actually I did
it for your own good it must be a team
we are
[Music]
hey oh dip definitely not my daughter
I'm the dip are all fluid transfer
activities like this I feel disgusting
cute I think I'm gonna like the future
one thing I want to know how's that damn
three seashells thing work thank you yes
none of us know what is the deal how
does it work comments let us know how
can I adopt the 360 how do I Implement a
three seashell situation in my life
man that was fun that was an absolute
blast oh my God I understand everything
except the seashells and how he
teleported to be next to him yes
that was Jack Black it was for like a
phrase
it was Jack Black okay it's gotta be
like maybe the first the I feel like the
90s and and like heading even into the
2000s there was this period where you
would have these like yeah Jack Black as
like featured extra like it happens and
Paul Rudd was doing video game
commercials Jack Black I'm sure they pop
up and stuff yeah running man I've also
never seen that oh me neither hey up
next let's do a double moving let's just
dive in oh my God there's a Sting theme
as well oh the 90s were exquisite
what's on right now
you guys can't hear any of this but also
this is get on Spotify
this is Sting really really region for
this is like staying you're you're
popular enough to we would get you
whatever even though your type of music
does not translate it's just sting and
cocaine as co-leads of the song like
that's a lot of cocaine oh wow this was
a what a ride this was an absolute blast
and I do gotta say like this to me
really does feel like and and I know
that we're we're disparate a couple of
years you know give or take but uh this
really does feel like the street fighter
to face-offs uh Mortal Kombat and what I
mean by that is like you know Mortal
Kombat as opposed to Street like Street
Fighters is like Non-Stop and madcap and
wild and wacky and Mortal Kombat
occasionally tries to slow down and have
mood
I feel like this is is like you know
you've got John Woo doing face off so
there are those moments where it wants
to be very dramatic whereas this is just
like we're going man we're just moving
the peach I could eat a peach for hours
oh my God but you finally saw that right
oh yeah okay I reacted to it on this
channel man another one you want to see
it go check it out boom
um but yeah what a journey this was this
was the street fighter like you're
totally that is such an accurate
description this was just a blast of two
actors doing their thing in an exact
script designed to let them do their
thing like that was just Joy yeah man
and it's like yeah there are a lot of
things that you can think about
especially in hindsight because yeah
you've got Stallone and you're like
Dread yeah freaking Rob Schneider's
around it's like yeah and uh and so like
it's fun in hindsight to see the sort of
overlapping in these kinds of movies but
uh but yeah I mean this was a total
blasting that's sure it it Harkens to I
feel like they make a number of Brave
New World references because as I
remember my vague recollection of that
book we read that in 1984 and it was
like oh here's one future that's clearly
you know a dystopia and and you know
fascist for various reasons and then
here is the Brave New World version
where it's supposed to be this sort of
sprinkle Utopia but but yeah but you
realize that's dystopian in its own way
if I remember correctly yeah and there
are also you know uh the one song sorry
I didn't mean to interrupt that's just a
moment it's all good cause the rest has
to be
Fizz so rest has to be Jingles
yeah it's like they took that idea of
like okay the Tranquil utopian future
maybe has some dark secrets lurking
beneath it or maybe there is value to
the shadow sides of life
um but yeah I thought they did just a
really nice job of realizing this world
like as madcap as this is like it's not
quite I don't think as like smart
surprisingly as like a Robocop but it
does have that future where you're like
you know what and especially watching
this you know uh 20 odd years removed
from when this came out originally like
this does feel like a a reasonably kind
of semi-plausible take on a future and I
think that it was credited as the new LA
Convention Center with new in all caps
by the way of course that must have been
they probably like made like a deal in
getting because they filmed like so much
of the movie in that in that one
location yeah so it's really interesting
like that was the future of then and now
it's like we go there yearly and it's
like just normal you know what I mean
like the new I like Adventure Center one
this movie had so many there was the LA
Convention Center and I feel like there
were a couple others as well
a couple times yeah and maybe even Long
Beach in there at one point like yeah
like this was like everything in the
future is based off of convention
Center's architecture because you need
that much space for Stallone and that
crew to blow stuff up yeah but it's like
I I appreciated the way that this drew
it sort of quirky future because in the
outset you're kind of like okay I see
the Wasteland Los Angeles used to be
before you know the big one and and the
reset and then you see the future it is
now and at first you're like oh this is
kind of peaceful and sort of nice and
and it draws I think a nice level of
humor out of that because it makes sense
as to why like everyone you meet
especially you're mostly meeting like
cops and and you know people in charge
and they all feel like children in a way
and they all behave like children in a
way and there's something oddly
endearing about that but that's also
quirky and fun to then see contrasted by
the Mania of Wesley Snipes and just the
you know Stone Cold badassness of
Stallone and and even that like you know
I like that they paired him with Sandra
Bullock because she is like so Plucky
and so you know affable in Good Nature
yeah and and Stallone like remains
himself but he softens in a way that is
ever so slight but you are fearing even
still this must have been right after
speed yeah it feels like there's some of
that in here this was I mean like and
Sandra Bullock like coming off of speed
like being the action heroin to cast and
like this was so
I and this is a this is a compliment but
this is so of the time in Wesley Snipes
the super popular martial arts Stallone
is like the big action guy they're
referencing Arnold Sandra Bullock is
like fresh off of speed it seems like
they've got a lot of In-House references
where like Joel Silver would not get
away with putting a Lethal Weapon three
posters equivalent in a today movie like
they literally were plugging stuff but I
love that it was all because it was the
future of the present so like 1993
lethal weapon's about to come out you've
got that poster and then that's the
future so they got all these Throwbacks
but none of it felt cheesy enough to
remove it actually like really worked
tonally and I really love the idea of
like La underground being like New York
where like there's that whole New York
City that's under New York present and I
love the the scabs being kind of the
good guys like they just want to eat and
I love the the sterile dystopian future
it's of like what the future could
become if either party or either
um idealized gold takes too much control
like yeah when I said just like I would
not let someone track me like I would
not let a plug be in my hand and like
they're doing neural link chips today
like they're literally starting human
trials like like elon's out there like
making Twitter burnt on fire and they're
gonna put human trials and I love the
goal of that is to help people with
seizures but the reality is you can't
run a website you shouldn't run people's
brains but my point is we're living in
an age where like
it's not far away and I love that this
was set in 10 years from now and I love
that this has a lot of like those look
like Teslas and yeah there's a lot of
stuff that really worked this age the
iPad well considering like like is this
is one of those views of the future I
feel like a lot of times you watch a
movie from the past depicting the future
and you're like oh how quaint yes this
is what you thought it would be and and
this video chatted on iPads that's a
major like if you think about 1993 how
futuristic is video chatting on an iPad
and it's like I feel like a lot of the
things they did here and even the
concept of cryopril like you know you
miss out on all that Free Labor not to
get too topical on you but like all
these things that they had all these
trappings of this future felt oddly not
too far-fetched again given that we are
close in time to when this is supposed
to take place but also too on that same
token I feel like all the cheeky pop
culture nods and and you know like
President Schwarzenegger and all these
various things aged pretty well too yes
those are all for the most part at least
for me watching this for you I think too
like watching this you're able to catch
all those references and like you know
they sing that one jingle I don't know
if that one jingle they sing okay five
Jingles were real I read them all they
were like Jingles of a time I think so
that that dog food wanted in so much
recognize but the joke still plays and
there are other ones that you do
recognize and uh and and there's even
that sort of like idiocracy I like you
watch a movie like that and you're like
yeah they must have taken some notes
like this with the whole Taco Bell thing
yeah which which was a major plot point
which was a major problem was the third
lead and now it's coming back to me and
I'm sure somebody in the comments has
already gotten to it but if I'm not
mistaken I think this might be the movie
where there's like in one territory
somewhere else in the world they
couldn't Clear Taco Bell so it's Pizza
Hut I think I could be wrong about that
but I feel like that is an aspect of
this here
um I love this I love this too I I I
think it's a new old classic yeah like
it's one of my movies I'm gonna watch
are going to be like I get Demolition
Man like it didn't lose itself to the
fact that I didn't grow up with it yeah
and it's like I love that you have these
two Central figures Who Remain
quintessential and yet you also like it
doesn't really focus as much on the
whole like what do we really do to fix
the future no there's not a lot of moral
quandary at the end because once they
get to that point they're just sort of
like I'll figure out what are we gonna
do now and he's like well like he
Stallone steps in and you think he's
gonna like you know start the throw the
first stone towards a better future and
he's he's just like uh no you guys will
figure it out like what do you want I'm
like they haven't figured it out that's
the whole point is like this way of of
living a rose it forced a certain handle
little people underground which is also
a very sort of well-worn sci-fi thing I
thought of you know a million things
like equilibrium comes to mind it's that
thing of we want to have the you know uh
difficult parts of humanity we don't all
want to conform to one sanded down
version of Life uh and so like it's
there I appreciate it I liked
um Edgar friendly and all that stuff and
what they stood for part of me was like
are are Stallone and and Wesley snipe's
gonna somehow Unite with the future yeah
all of them yeah the the the what's this
is crazy yeah the scraps uh you know
yeah I Liked It ultimately comes down to
yeah those guys are not gonna get
together but you know there is a better
future that will blend out of these too
and I love that they didn't spoon feed
us like I love that it's gonna be a
struggle but I also I was gonna say I I
don't think I've seen a cover of a VHS
more yes like that too facing each other
Demolition Man maybe the cover of a
movie that I've seen the most having not
seen the movie like there's like those
iconic covers this is up there and I've
also and I'll admit this I don't know if
you've seen it I've never seen White Men
Can't Jump I haven't two
comments basketball time do you want us
to watch White Men Can't Jump because
I'm a big Woody Harrelson and a big
Wesley Snipes fan oh yeah those are two
w named actors I appreciate very much in
one motion picture
um yeah this was uh absolutely
incredible I had such a good time uh
this was in part because you love Lisa
is one of the ones people recommended
also uh this is a movie that I think
um everyone needs to see like this is
one of those like you have to and so I'm
so glad I did this was like an absolute
blast yeah and two if you like just real
quick if you if you like action also
like it's the even though there were
times I wish they would shoot some of
them you know you've got Wesley Snipes
martial arts like sometimes I wish to be
more of that I thought all the action
all the stuns all the effects physical
and otherwise really Blended well
together to make something that felt
like you know Punchy and uh and every
you know hit every explosion you really
felt that you know five years before
blade I know crazy it's five years so
glad you found this up late yeah it's so
good yeah
is here man what a guy uh well let's get
a patreon shout out in here who is gonna
be our demolition man or woman today oh
who's lucky who's the lucky one was our
demolition
who do we got Adelia Chamberlain you're
the demolition woman of the reject
Nation I feel like you you would be the
John Spartan well she's so futuristic
and tech savvy that's true she would be
able to hack in interfaces and set up
the future and prepare one of us
ignorant people trapped in the cryo to
what the future is until it should be
able to catch us up Hondo p and she's
got that good moral compass but she's
also not afraid to give you smack if you
need it she's our Sandra Bullock
absolutely she's aware of the 20th
century she's a little ahead of us and
also smack you can eat it yeah yeah a
little bit of Sandy a little bit of
Stallone a little appreciate that slidey
we'll call you
slidey that's a great sure there's
nothing better than that no no sir
we're done here keeping that name that's
what you're gonna get Adelia thank you
very much reject Nation thank you very
much remember to leave a like on your
way out remember to leave a comment on
your way out you want us to watch some
White Men Can't Jump you want to Swatch
some running man do you want to watch
some other movie The Man in the title I
realized I was very popular in the 90s
you want us to watch something you leave
a comment below I'm enjoying the Snipes
of sons and I'm enjoying us enjoy you
enjoy us enjoy the sniper songs we will
talk to you very soon much love
rejection
foreign
[Music]